okay Peppa looks like we're freakin back
and we're playing the ant ray you can't
jump up the window I sent you up there
for anything okay I can take this not
that I miss our trash can anything in
you I'll take this
Bram hat yeah a little butcher shop I
too love butchering my mate oh sure
price is right but I guess I have to
have really nice Danger Danger Roberts
had family danger hunting Hanks in here
should I get that bottle of turpentine
of course
well it served either your paint thinner
can I paint this
mr. painter what is that Joker
I'm just people gonna see me it's a
glass window hello sir hello mr. panner
hey looking for someone there's a note
pal I sky can I help you
alright still a lot yeah I got out
corpse lighter
Oh
only guys allergic to bees pants dry it
up can't like eat it up good night now
let me go back to ya like that [ __ ]
I'll take this broken plate off your
hand thank you
there's something round on their hair oh
there's some dust and dust stops me you
know holes in it but not big enough for
fingers there's a bone there mm that's
that
now take that me talk that there the
check yeah the future has a yellow grass
Hannah anyways you says cover it
hey get over here I don't like when you
click an item he stops immediately
that's a best bar thank ya arrest a iron
bars let me say back to that past
[Music]
locked danger Robinson family danger
okay can I use this by now
that's right
take this polish man
can I get torch
get it get it no can i stir this up he
can't he can't do that
No
any in here
now SEC bonesaw
go down the stree it's attached to
okay
can I move this now
hello mr. bouncer here we're partnering
for Danny my starbound Saul here
reporting for daddy
oh I worked ah good old syringe and
outside edge and there's the train
[Music]
okay so I think I'm going to take some
turpentine and check that in the bees
and then light it that sounds like a
crazy a plan it's gonna get dizzy
[Music]
Dennett out
what
oh my giving me a spark I get can I put
the term caffeine in Ted here um when I
got back that my got back to the
beginning
[Music]
what did I check this out bounds pants
he has Turkmen Tina running he can't he
can't do that
no how about yo sorry
[Music]
right there I open this
Danya like this
turpentine will clear it up
so if I want to I need to light
something closer to the nest
[Music]
so maybe I gotta go down there and light
something
which stuff
yeah just stick that ruble up
[Music]
okay it's soaked light it all right go
just get those beers away from the door
now and now when I'm saying
nobody likes BAE's especially noise a
base that I'll check in going to have to
go back and forth for like every single
door yeah this pile end of the chapter